le trio de david contre goliath en
italie les pizzas locales l'ont emporté
sur la chaîne américaine domino's pizza
qui a tout simplement décidé de se
retirer du pays le groupe avait pour
ambition de s'implanter au pays de la
pizza mais sept ans après leur arrivée
domino's pizza est contraint de fermer
ses 29 établissements dans le pays face
à la résistance des pizzaïolos
traditionnelle en 2015 euro prévoyait
d'ouvrir 880 magasins d'ici 2030 en se
différenciant avec son service de
livraison et sa pizza à l'ananas mais
avec le confinement beaucoup de
pizzaïolo locaux ont signé des accords
avec des services de livraison comme des
livres ou just hits ou encore le nouveau